The bubonic plague is still killing people
all around the globe - but should we be worried?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and we’ve
all heard of the bubonic plague.
It’s the devastating disease that eats your
body from the inside out - and was responsible
for the deaths of over 75 million people in
the 14th century, including over half of Europe’s
entire population.
What you might not know, is that the plague
is still around - and it’s still killing
people!
A city in China called Yumen was sealed off
last week, after a 38-year-old man died of
the disease, after coming into contact with
an infected marmot.
And 151 others in that city were placed under
“quarantine,” for coming into contact
with him.
But is this the same plague that killed all
those people hundreds of years ago?
Well… in a nutshell, yes!
The plague that existed in the 14th century,
now commonly referred to as the Black Death,
was caused by a bacterium called Yersinia
pestis - and it’s almost identical to the
one that exists today.
That single strain, which was originally transferred
to humans by fleas, can cause 3 separate versions
of the plague.
There’s the bubonic plague (which is the
simplest version), the pneumonic plague (which
is a lung infection that’s rarer, but more
devastating than the other two forms), and
the septicemic plague (which is the rarest
of the three, and causes all of the blood
in your body to clot.)
Some reports are saying the man in China died
of the pneumonic version, while others say
it was septicemic or bubonic.
But it’s entirely possible that all three
of those are true.
The bubonic plague typically appears in localized
areas, like the lymph nodes - but without
treatment, the infection can spread to your
blood, morphing into the septicemic version.
From there, if it settles into the lungs - it
can transform once again into the pneumonic
version - which is easily the most contagious
form of the three.
It’s the septicemic version, though, that
gives the Black Death its name.
The lack of blood flow, causes the extremities
to turn black, until your limbs literally
fall off.
And all of this can happen within a span of
24 hours.
It’s terrifying stuff, and even though the
bubonic plague still exists - even in developed
countries, like the United States - it’s
now completely curable with antibiotics.
Just last week, 4 Colorado residents were
diagnosed with the pneumonic plague after
coming into contact with an infected dog.
All of them have now been treated, and are
expected to live.
But the man who died in China, likely didn’t
have access to antibiotics, which explains
why such drastic measures were taken.
Disease control specialists quarantined all
30,000 residents in Yumen for 9 days - to
perform disinfection as well as rat extermination.
They also ran education sessions to raise
awareness of how people can guard themselves
against infection.
As of today, the quarantine has been lifted
- and no more deaths are expected.
At least, for now.
People who live in rural areas with lots of
rodents, are far more at risk than the general
population.
But it still stands, that anyone can theoretically
contract the plague.
As long as you catch it early, though - and
have access to antibiotics - there’s really
no need to worry.
Yay, modern medicine!
As always, if you guys have questions, comments,
anything you wanna say about this episode
- just leave em in the comments below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!